anime baseball so mean anime baseball oh
my god
watching Sam without even not any sound
is funny oh good shot you're not allowed
to look back if you were standing at the
plate and you should ever look back at
the catcher to see where he's setting up
that ball will go right by your [ __ ]
head and take off the end of your ear
that [ __ ] is going to give you some
Chin Music or he will drill you in the
ribs real quick I seriously where are we
today we are at Cannon and Hollywood
goal is to rent or borrow equipment to
try it out see if it actually benefits
us maybe we can try out their cannon a
dd DSLR and their c100 mark to cinema
series
alright let's see yeah alex is here
alright trolden algorithmic that picture
on purpose so everybody has bad pictures
as long as they get all the celebrities
be posting snap stars we're like well
that's what we do but that's gonna go
back the other way
as soon as the tracking is good enough
to make attractive filters then soon
we'll just let me apply my makeup my
evening look alright I look super
attractive yeah then you'll only have to
apply makeup when you actually go out
into public yeah what you learn how to
do because of your vr avatar stepping
out yeah right yeah what does this mean
how do we how do we react to be ready
for the future we're just old enough we
can start relaxing on our porch and
watching all the kids do down the ship
yeah yeah just kills more jobs I love
that yes Alan hi nice to meet you
we actually have no candy camp no
kinship right argument was we need low
light autofocus after that it's audio
how we shoot a lot of the behind the
scenes as well as we try to find the
angle with a microphone yeah there's
always on counter mic sure and then once
we land there we find the shapes in the
lines of the composition then we got it
cool the representation of brightness so
you can trust that here he's got the
autofocus inside of there 400 millimeter
you guys want to see that we're born in
90 what never 90 [ __ ] all of my just
answer twice as old as soon are you
kidding me I did all my pants what look
I've got some pants from some Levi's
from 1972 when I was you know far
where's my date usually I have a date
but no no no I write a big date with a
sharpie on my pants and I can't find but
they on the back pocket which means I'd
have to go drop my drawers
yeah yeah well no no I just so got
Allen's big enough make of us they
didn't think their job was here
job's done nick is editing the stuff of
that brain in soccer Alamos he's like
that's not gonna happen
the point was raised that makeup artists
are gonna be irrelevant in broadcast and
film personally I don't think that's
gonna happen for a while at least a
decade basically Brandon's point is that
facial tracking is getting so good at
such an exponential rate that within a
matter of years it's gonna be so perfect
and flawless that kind of removes the
need for makeup I mean you can make the
person look like whoever you want you
can make the person instead of just
anti-shine powder it's Obama the
snapchat filter of ten years from now
just imagine flipping through a news
station everyone on this station is
Obama I mean remember the googly eye
video he accidentally turned on the
automation button that put googly eyes
on all the stuff going out of the
broadcast suite that's gonna be a real
thing in less than ten years like at
least the possibility will be real but I
think mostly what brain is talking about
is the what if he wasn't one of the
first people to predict that from the
nakedness brandon is no true dolmas
Nostradamus reincarnated no true tapas
Dallas I was like no Venus